Marvel Jesus just received their own
card in Magic the Gathering, and it has
raised a whole heap of questions about
how their ability interacts with other
cards. So, let's go over every single
interaction with Deadpool Trading Card.
As always, let's start at the beginning
and review the card and clarify exactly
what it does. Deadpool trading card is a
red black four mana 53 legendary mutant
mercenary hero that says as Deadpool
enters you may exchange his text box and
another creatures at the beginning of
your upkeep you lose three life pay
three sacrifice this creature each other
player draws a card effectively what we
have here is the creature version of the
infinity card exchange of words but
because it's creature. It's much more
powerful. The game plan with this card
is to simply swap your opponent's best
creature text box with Deadpool's awful
one. Now, that's something to clarify.
What is a text box and what does that
encompass? The comprehensive rules
describes the text box as part of a
card. The text box is printed on the
lower half of the card and contains the
card's rules text, reminder text, and
flavor text. So, Deadpool only swaps
this part of the card and not things
like typeline, power and toughness, and
loyalty. The next thing we need to
clarify is the wording on Deadpool's
swap ability. As we can see, it uses the
template as this permanent enters
So, as per rule
614.1C, we know that this is a
replacement effect. Effectively,
Deadpool's swap ability happens after
the Deadpool spell resolves, but before
Deadpool enters the battlefield. So,
what this means is Deadpool will enter
play with the text box they swapped
with. So, they'll trigger the enter the
battlefield ability of the card they
swapped text boxes with. The easiest
card to compare Deadpool with is clone.
Those familiar with the game know that
clones will trigger any enters abilities
of the card they just copied. And
Deadpool works in the exact same way.
There's one special case that's a bit
advanced, but we'll leave that one till
the end. The final thing I want to
mention about the textbox swap ability
is swapping with cards that have
abilities that mention the name of a
card. things like the regenerate ability
on Wolverine best there is and the
shuffle ability on Ulamog the infinite
guy. It's really important to understand
that these names are simply shorthand
for this game object as per rule
2011.5. These names are not explicitly
referencing cards called Wolverine or
Ulamog. The rules then go on to explain
if a card with an ability like the one
on Wolverine Best there is gained by
another card, for example, Marvin the
Murderous Mimic, when the second card
gains that ability, the name on the
ability should be treated as the name of
the second card. Now, this rule is not
to be confused with cards that
specifically reference a card with a
certain name. For example, hair
apparent. If Deadpool swapped text boxes
with hair apparent, the two instances of
the name hair apparent will not change
to Deadpool. This is because these
abilities aren't referencing this
particular instance of the card. They're
referencing cards in general named hair
apparent. The easiest way to spot this
and avoid any confusion is to simply
look for the word named. Okay, now we
understand the surface of this ability.
Let's dive into some interesting
interactions that you might come across.
Starting with clones. Let's say we had a
Deadpool that swapped text boxes with a
Lanir elf. If we then cast spark double
copying the Deadpool, what would Spark
Double look like when it enters the
battlefield? Well, firstly, we need to
understand what type of effect
Deadpool's first ability is. We know
it's a replacement effect, but it also
changes the printed text on the card.
So, that means we're dealing with a
continuous effect. So, that means, yes,
that's right. We've got to talk about
layers. Deadpool's first ability is a
text changing effect. And if we look at
the layers list, that occurs on layer 3.
Now, copy effects like what we've seen
on clone, they apply in layer 1. This is
important to understand as when we look
to apply the layers, we always apply
them in order of the layers list from
top to bottom. So in the case of our
example, when we apply Spark Double's
copy effect, that happens before
Deadpool has swapped text boxes. So all
that means is that Spark Double will
enter as a non-leendary copy of the
original base Deadpool with no land of
war ability. This also means that the
Spark double copy will get to swap text
boxes with another creature in play as
well. as don't forget Deadpool's first
ability is a replacement effect just
like clones and spark doubles ability.
So it must happen before the creature
enters play. This is also relevant to
know for those players looking to use
blade of selves or the master multiplied
to generate a bunch of Deadpools through
myriad. No matter what Deadpool's text
box is, the myriad copies will always
enter as base copies of
Deadpool. But just like with Spark
Double and Clone, you'll be able to use
those tokens to swap text boxes with
your opponent's creatures.
Now, unless you have the mastered
multiplied mirror box or mirror gallery
after those tokens enter, you'll have to
put them in the graveyard due to the
legendary rule. And it's here it's worth
pointing out that once Deadpool swaps
text boxes with a creature, that swap
lasts
indefinitely. The only way to give a
creature its text box back is for it to
change zones. So, if your creature has
its text box stolen, you can use a card
like Cloud Shift to blink your creature
to give it back its original text box.
Again, it's worth noting that doing this
won't change Deadpool's text box back.
They'll still have whatever ability
they've stolen. And before I forget, if
you use Deadpool's swap ability with a
clone that's a copy of something else,
Deadpool will get the text box of
whatever the clone had copied. This is
thanks to layers and timestamps. Let's
move on to some more creature examples.
If Deadpool swaps text boxes with a
creature that's mutated, they get the
original creatures text box plus all the
mutated abilities it had. And the
mutated creature is left with Deadpool's
text box. Mutated creatures are treated
as a single creature just like melded
creatures. A creature that Deadpool
would love to swap with is any of the
enduring creatures from Duskmon. They
have the special ability that if they
die, they return to the battlefield and
become an enchantment. If Deadpool has
this ability, when they died, they would
indeed return to the battlefield as an
enchantment, but as they entered, they
would once again be able to swap text
boxes with another creature. As we
previously mentioned, Deadpool only
swaps text boxes, so he'll still be an
enchantment and not a creature when they
re-enter. If Deadpool swaps with a
creature or permanent that has transform
and then a spell or ability instructs
Deadpool to try and transform, as per
rule
701.28C, because Deadpool isn't a
transforming doubleface card, nothing
will happen. One of the final things we
need to look at is CDAS, characteristic
defining abilities. Characteristic
defining abilities are just that,
abilities that define certain
characteristics of a card. There's the
CDA keywords of changeling and devoid.
And then there's simple statements like
the ones on
transgender
adventurer. I think the two most
well-known CDAs are the ones on Tarmago
and Lord of Extinction. It's pretty
self-explanatory what happens when
Deadpool swaps with creatures with the
keyword CDAs and statements. But what
about the creatures with power and
toughness CDAs? If Deadpool swaps text
boxes with Lord of Extinction, Deadpool
will now have power and toughness equal
to the number of cards in all
graveyards. And because nothing is
defining the power of toughness of Lord
of Extinction, by default, they'll
become a 000 and will be put into the
graveyard when state-based actions
happen. If Deadpool swapped with
Tarmago, you guessed it, Deadpool's
power would be equal to the number of
card types among all cards in all
graveyards, and its toughness is equal
to that number plus one.
The goify would be a 01 in this case
with Deadpool's ability, and that's
purely thanks to the one on Tamago's
toughness
indicator. Now, let's look at some
non-creature permanence that Deadpool
can swap with under the right
conditions. Starting with Planaines
Walkers. Let's say you control a Kito
Bane of Nightmares, which says during
your turn, as long as Kito has one or
more loyalty counters on him, he's a 34
ninja creature and has hexroof. And then
during your turn, I flash in Deadpool
thanks to Tofuri, Mage of Zir. And then
I use Deadpool's ability to swap with
Kaio because remember Deadpool's ability
doesn't
target. What would Deadpool and Kaio
look like? As I mentioned earlier,
Deadpool only swaps text boxes with
Kaio. So that would only include the
portion of the card that has Kaiito's
passive and loyalty abilities. It would
not swap types or give Deadpool a
starting loyalty. So after Deadpool
enters, there'll still be a legendary
creature mutant mercenary hero that's a
53 with three loyalty
abilities. Kito, on the other hand, will
simply be a legendary planaineswalker
with some amount of loyalty, no loyalty
abilities, and Deadpool's text box
instead.
When the turn passes back to me, I can
activate one of the loyalty abilities on
Deadpool by paying the loyalty cost,
remembering here that as soon as
Deadpool has a loyalty counter placed on
them, they'll become a 34 ninja with
hexroof thanks to that
passive. Now, when creatures get
Planaineswalker loyalty abilities,
there's some rules to keep in mind. You
can still only activate one loyalty
ability permanent with loyalty abilities
per turn. And because Deadpool is still
a creature and not a Planaineswalker,
they won't lose loyalty when they take
damage and won't be put into the
graveyard when they have zero
loyalty. Enchantments, artifacts, and
lands work exactly how you think.
Although, notably, if Deadpool swaps
with an equipment, he can't equip
himself to other creatures. And because
Deadpool themselves is not equipped to
anything, they won't trigger any
abilities that says when equipped
creature attacks. And besides the bestow
creatures, auras never stick around long
enough for Deadpool to swap abilities
with them. So don't worry about that.
For lands, Deadpool would get the
appropriate mana abilities, as well as
any abilities that mention if Deadpool
would enter tapped or not. But notably,
if Deadpool swapped text boxes with a
dried arbor, Deadpool would have no
abilities and dried arbor would have
Deadpool's text box and still tap for
green
mana. This is because having the mana
ability is intrinsic to having one of
the basic land types. It's certainly
possible for Deadpool to swap with a
battle. And just like with creatures,
Deadpool can trigger the battle's ETB,
but outside of that, nothing else fancy
happens with Deadpool or the battle. The
battle continues to operate as normal,
and Deadpool won't attempt to transform
itself when they're put into the
graveyard. Battles transforming when
they lose defense counters is intrinsic
to battles. is not tied in any way to
the ability. Okay, last permanent to
talk about before we move on to some
advanced rules. Sagas. If Deadpool
manages to swap text boxes with their
saga, perhaps the most interesting thing
that will happen in this interaction is
that after Deadpool enters, the saga
will be placed into the graveyard due to
state-based actions. This is because
Deadpool removes all the chapters from
the saga. They're all stored within the
text box. And as per rule
714.4, if a saga has a number of law
counters greater than or equal to the
final chapter number, in this case zero,
the saga's controller sacrifices it as a
state-based
action. This is the same reason that
blood moon instantly causes Öza's saga
to be sacrificed. The other big thing to
note is that placing a law counter on a
saga is intrinsic to being a saga as per
rule
714.3b. So this means Deadpool will not
naturally gain law counters. You'll need
to find a way to move law counters about
with something like nesting grounds. And
if you do manage to put a law counter on
Deadpool, it will trigger the relevant
chapter ability. And if you do manage to
put more law counters than Deadpool has
chapters, you won't be forced to
sacrifice Deadpool. Now, this whole
ruling is really important to keep in
mind, especially with the saga creatures
that are coming with the release of the
Final Fantasy set. Deadpool will
essentially instakill the Final Fantasy
summons. Okay, let's talk some advanced
rules from anywhere abilities. One of
the most interesting interactions I've
seen is Deadpool and his interaction
with the three original Eldrazi Titans,
and this seems to trip a lot of people
up. We know that if Deadpool swapped
text boxes with a creature that had a
dies or leaves the battlefield ability,
they would trigger when they died or
left the battlefield. This is because of
rule 603.10A,
10A, which basically says the game can
look back in time to see if anything
needs to trigger when something is put
into the graveyard. This is the same
reason that Blood Artist triggers for
all the creatures dying, including
itself, when someone casts Wrath of God.
However, if Deadpool swaps text boxes
with one of the original three Eldrazi
titans and eventually ended up in the
graveyard, they would not trigger the
shuffle ability. And this all comes down
to the words on the ability from
anywhere and rule
603.6c, which says, "An ability that
triggers when a card is put into a zone
from anywhere is never treated as a
leaves the battlefield ability, even if
an object is put into that zone from the
battlefield. Effectively, all that means
is this ability doesn't look back in
time to see what the card was like. It
simply checks the card in the right here
and now, which means Deadpool is in the
graveyard with his original text box and
no graveyard shuffling
ability. It's worth noting that if the
Eldrazi Titan that had their text box
swapped with Deadpool, ended up in the
graveyard, probably thanks to their
newfound sacrifice ability, they would
trigger their own shuffle ability
because again, the ability checks once
the creature is in the graveyard. And by
that time, they have their own text box
back. This is the exact same interaction
that happens between Emercle, the Aon
Stor being put into the graveyard with a
dress down in play. Another interesting
interaction to point out is how Deadpool
works with humility. Let's say you had
humility in play and cast Deadpool.
Would Deadpool still swap text boxes?
Now, we know that the game can look back
in time to check for an effect, but with
replacement effects, the game can
actually look forward in time, too. In
this case, rule
614.12 tells us that when a permanent
with a replacement effect is entering
the battlefield, we look at the rules
text of the card, telling us how the
replacement effect is going to change
this entering the battlefield event. But
we also must consider any continuous
effects that would apply to it once it's
on the battlefield.
In this case, humility would make it so
that Deadpool would have no abilities.
So, this simply means that Deadpool
would not swap text boxes with any
creature as they're entering if there is
a humility in play. Again, if you're
wanting to compare, this is the same
thing that would happen to a clone if
they entered while there was a humility
in play. They would enter as a 1 one and
wouldn't become a copy of something.
The final interaction I wanted to talk
about is Deadpool swapping text boxes
with Essence of the Wild. Essence of the
Wild says, "Creatures you control enter
as a copy of this
creature." All that you need to know is
that every creature you play going
forward will enter as a 53 Deadpool with
the ability creatures you control enter
as a copy of this creature. And then
they die due to state-based actions.
Here's why. It's basically the same as
the humility example. The game will look
forward and see that the creature will
enter as a essence of Deadpool.
Therefore, none of the creatures
replacement effects will happen and none
of the creatures triggered abilities
will trigger. Do not swap text boxes
with Essence of the Wild. You have been
warned. Now, that is practically every
interaction you need to know for
Deadpool trading card. Be sure to like
the video if you learned something and
subscribe because if you don't, Deadpool
will kill the magic
multiverse. Thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one.